is basically they cuff your hand
to the hook the floor hooked up and your
feet also are cuffed to that so you're
squatting
yeah and leave you in that position for
like hours somebody days
you can't go to the toilet
so you you defecate
urinate on yourself
even though you're screaming they got
loud music playing and it's normally it
was the rock music like heavy metal
music which we're not used I'm not used
to and it's not really Pleasant video
that kind of music person but it's on
for like 24 hours 48 hours so sometimes
you'll be there for like a day two days
it's in the air smoke on fire room
strobe lights on
um lights up and they make it really
cold so they put aircon really cold are
you there are in that position another
your leg starts cramping your calves
cramp
hamstrings and camping your bums
cramping comes in your belly Comes Here
Comes you can't you can't get out